[Music]
in no more toilet sex news oh yeah
goodbye vetting in chief I know right
good news
the town is planning to install public
toilets at combat sexual activity by
spraying users with water
general what was that was that Tommy why
sure it's funny but like not really wait
you're the only one that laughs though
oh I see was Han yeah it's kind of funny
it's kind of funny it was funny but then
what made a funnier was my reaction so
that's yeah I don't like to explain like
the things that I construct and do by
just did it yeah you just made art and I
like don't want to explain you know why
the [ __ ] okay you're like Banksy but
people see your face they laugh but it's
like if I have to explain it it's like
oh okay well [ __ ] you ruined it the
Magic's gone now what do you got there
you know what are you doing well I have
this brand deal from glasses USA and I
just want you guys to know if you go not
just kidding all right so this Welsh
seaside town is planning to install
these new public toilets that have all
these preventative measures to have for
people to have sex there so it has a
squealing alarm the doors shoot open so
the world can see them and in chili
spray of water
wait Chili's what rate I think you'd
like to turn off to it's like a home
alone house yeah but like what what what
what triggers these things because I
just want to take a [ __ ] sometimes I'm
sure it does it after like I don't know
10 minutes 15 minutes sometimes my shits
are pretty long though here's the public
when we had already up you're really
[ __ ] and you like put your arms in
the air so like what drab the walls and
[ __ ] like they're saying that there will
be weight sensors that detect the
entrance of one or more than one person
I mean well what about people in Texas
well this is an or Louisiana who are
visiting they're just like 500 pounds
400 pounds what about if I if I'm having
diarrhea and Ryan needs to go in with me
- what if we got a tag team the dirt
something that someone
comment they ended up saying uh would
they say to make sure I don't choke in
there this is absolutely terrifying am i
I'm a disabled person who falls a lot
and occasionally needs assistant am I
going to have to need to start looking
up whether I'll be able to use public
conveniences and best in diapers my
friend can you imagine
so he's like this right girl okay well
she's like that homeboy SWAT wiping her
[ __ ] ass right and then the and
everyone's like looking at their like ah
literally would do things like [ __ ]
they don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on why is my toilet attacking me I know
I do
you're like in mid motion like oh I'm
just trying to wipe my friends ass what
the [ __ ] they're not reading cnn.com
about this [ __ ] and you're who would
know I mean you wouldn't even know
wouldn't know you just go to the toilet
what if you have an adult child and then
you need to help them go to the bathroom
and you go inside don't child adult
child or even over there going to the
loo you're just trying to go to the loo
yeah that's my point in order to prevent
sleepers from taking shelter inside or
heroin users they will have a warning
message play after a certain amount of
time and morning and then the light like
Jo mentioned and the heating will shut
off what am i if you're like how it
constipated and you have it like because
that's one of the things I always worry
about cuz you know how in LA it's time
the pump and it's washed every time
every time because the [ __ ] people do
crack in there or whatever so I'm like I
would hate to have to take a [ __ ] and
sometimes I take really long [ __ ] yeah
where it's like have you ever been
sitting on like one of those automatic
toilets like flushing things and you
just sit for too long and it flushes i
got'em get pulled out yeah yeah really
it's strong sometimes it pull so hard
I'm like my butthole the flippin door
puts his butt all the way inside so that
he could make sure that it
water has a bidet yeah Bart always goes
in there with a Reggie removes the
toilet seat he's like I never know why
they put this [ __ ] thing the lid you
know it's a little late why don't I sit
on the lid I'm not an idiot
being inside of it you know they say
that there will be an automated ten
minute deep clean process that will take
place every single night and these
toilets will cost the town two hundred
thousand dollars maybe it's a good idea
because if everyone's [ __ ] and
pissing all over the place yeah not only
that but users will pay an undetermined
feeds and access well you just pay a guy
to sit in there [ __ ] if he's if he
sees people in there [ __ ]
he hits a button a strobe light goes off
and the [ __ ] Annabelle doll draws in
like drops from the ceiling that was it
that wasn't the direction I thought
you're gonna go with I thought to the
whole thing like ejector seat Oh like
out the ceiling that Joe show me where
the guy goes off the wall it goes down
ski school
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
can you imagine the [ __ ] trust issues
that you would have like just to the
rest of your life like can I go to sleep
like I'm just having this anxiety but
something getting flipped out of my bed
I get the bill the next level japanese
pranks though like they make everything
in your life you do right that's exactly
why they should follow more everybody
goes to do it though I would love
nothing more like 24 hours of period
it's like a scooby-doo house like being
flipped in and out of things yes please
yes please just come with me to do a TV
show pish there's nothing better in the
world you could it's not stop laughter
yeah no only gets hurt
well except for this poor guy but we'll
just said somebody he's getting paid
he's rich actually they'll be like oh
good okay did you know this guy profits
off of his business and people will be
like oh he's four how do you feel about
taxes Steve it was this one thing I read
about like an old school Europe the way
that they did porta potties is this guy
had a big [ __ ] coat right and then he
had a bucket and if you need to take a
[ __ ] or whatever you give him some money
and you drunk the [ __ ] yeah and he
covers you so yeah so if your lady or
whatever you like I got [ __ ] gold
right so you pay the guy and then you
just sit on the bucket like this and he
comes around with his KPD hey [ __ ] you
do your [ __ ] any coming why didn't he
just have like [ __ ] shower curtains
and he's removed himself out of the is
hand invented it yet oh God it's kind of
what Mel sold back that's he's running
around with a bucket of [ __ ] cuz it's
dropping into air what if you're like
Ryan no and he takes forever and the
guy's like hey how's it going in there
does he charge by the hour other people
around me like publicly my face being
shown no never had to rush home have
your bidding I'm gonna bout to [ __ ] my
[ __ ] car yeah yeah no surprise for me
I never know when I feel like I need to
take a [ __ ] and when you know that
doesn't it hit you oh no it's no because
then when I'm peeing that's when I'm
like oh by the way I guys take a [ __ ]
and then I'll just [ __ ] while I'm peeing
until I pee frequently throughout the
day they [ __ ] frequently - no nothing I
should every time I that's I could [ __ ]
frequently yeah but I don't know like I
I don't I can't really Wow
anyway I'm gonna show you guys the
photos of these I want to hear more
about your [ __ ] yeah why are you so
waiting it's so weird about it just want
to know but whoa that's pretty legit
that's a nice one it looks like a
[ __ ] fake rendering though it is
really good
you know what I'm gonna tell you guys
the truth right now okay no there's no
shows yeah
oh man you found out I've been lying to
the world man like I just got to come
out
it's a computer one right no it has it's
a spout glass like I can get
prescription in it but I never got it at
all
no but you the screen thing on it so
like protect you it's an anti glare or
whatever yeah yeah yeah just leave it on
yeah a lot of them have that you're
right there's no but I didn't put
prescription on so I just want to let
people know I just want to be fully
transparent that I don't have like your
glasses
thank you for not being like all the
other youtubers are hiding yeah you know
what I mean I don't want to lie those
are fashion very brave they look like
what a porn director calls a nerdy girl
yeah that's true porn boy you look at
porn boy this wide in a library porn boy
we knew John Rowe yeah new genre quite a
library [ __ ] me please alright so
another Twitter user responded to this
the toilet thing and they wrote anti
shagging measures that will be triggered
triggered by innocent users is one thing
but measures against rough sleeping if
someone's homeless and desperate enough
to sleep in public toilets they need
help not technology to shoo them away
they open your [ __ ] house for them
yeah they obviously don't live in the
city let you sleep in your living that's
true because if I gotta take a [ __ ] at
midnight and I open a door there's a
homeless guy jacking off inside there
man what the [ __ ] there's a Haiti of
mine shut the [ __ ] door
jerk turn the stroke I'll have another
minutes me he's like I like to open my
mouth and it shoots in my mouth we get
over the edge poor guy I think all those
people have great hearts but ours is how
big is their heart cuz I want them to
open all of their extra rooms for these
people's yep well they're all way they
always live in mansions and far away
from the rest of us they have no idea
how the world works they should live in
downtown LA they're shielded by the
suburbs that'll change your perspective
I know it did for me well yeah we'd only
lasted eight months baby all it did was
make me feel like I belong in with my
people in Skid Row what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]